a powerful storm that hammered parts of
the south is being blamed for at least
five deaths including a woman and her
two children people living in some areas
of Texas are waking up to devastation
after severe storms tore through the
state yesterday at least one twister
touched down near Texas A&M University
today more than six million people are
under the threat of severe weather in
parts of Mississippi Louisiana and
Alabama
Omar Villafranca reports on the damage
the scenes in San Augustine Texas
overnight showed the aftermath of the
tornadoes destruction brick buildings
reduced to rubble
power lines wiped out and roofs ripped
off buildings first responders rescued
several people trapped inside their
homes winds were so strong it was
reported debris was thrown 15,000 feet
into the air
hear what sounded like a plane or train
there's just this black cloud right
above us and I see some swirling and so
I kind of peeked around the corner I
just see debris just swirling in Bryan
Texas the damage was just as severe
water rushed into homes where a tornado
left gaping holes in walls and ceilings
we still have to assess the our roadways
and look for high water any kind of
flooding an area hundreds of miles away
a tornado tore through the Louisiana
Tech campus leaving a trail of
destruction in its path back in Texas
people emerge to see their backyards
destroyed as long as everybody's okay
that's what's really important you know
we'll put the fences up and we'll help
each other